[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
b b
b
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien, je vais envoyer une petite lettre à mon
DJ local et c'est une lettre dping Rec Je veux que mon
chy
joue Je me retourne un peu, je dois le faire  ici encore
[Musique]
aujourd'hui tu connais
coeur
tu
[Musique]
rock rock un autre roll over B over raconte
les
actualités [Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
n
[Musique]
elle se tortille comme une danse gloworm comme une
conversation d'épinards  J'ai un partenaire fou pour le voir
réel et
rock, elle a un centime, la musique ne
s'arrêtera jamais. B
L'homme se retourne,
l'homme se retourne
[Musique]
[Musique] pour dire à Chowski la nouvelle
]
[Musique]
h aux petites
heures, c'est à ce moment-là que je pense à [
Musique]
toi aux petites
heures [Musique] c'est à ce moment-là que je de
toi,
je me demande si tu
[Musique] te
souviens encore de toutes les choses douces que nous avons utilisées  à
[Musique]
faire et une
salle Wheeling Je m'assois seul et je pense à
[Musique]
toi
et une petite
pièce Je m'assois
seul et je pense à
[Musique]
toi Je me demande si tu te
souviens encore de toutes les choses douces que nous
utilisions  à
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique] faire [Musique] [Musique]
aller [Musique
]
[Rires] [Musique
] [
Rires] [Musique]
oh [Musique
]
oh [
Musique]
ouais
[Rires]
[Musique]
il
[  Musique]
une petite
chanson un
shant un petit
souvenir [Musique] un petit
baiser d'autrefois était
[Musique]
oui celui que
j'aime vraiment le seul pour
moi moi [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Rires  ]
[Musique]
Dans la chaleur de la journée dans l'
Alabama mobile, je travaille sur le chemin de fer avec l'
acier qui conduit, je dois gagner de l'
argent grâce à des chaussures toutes neuves,
j'essaie de trouver quelqu'un qui enlève ces BL,
elle ne m'aime pas, j'entends chanter  au
soleil PR à venir quand mon travail
[Musique]
est
w [
Musique]
[Rires] [
[Musique]
n
tout le monde se bouscule, saute partout pour
ramasser l'argent TR à T se jette
dans un  panique sur le point de devenir fou en essayant de
faire sortir les ouvriers du chemin du train J
murmure fort longtemps je ne peux pas arrêter le train
Laisse le rouler
[Musique]
On [
Musique] [
Musique]
a [
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
on fais ta
fête
Sher devrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
fête B
[Musique]
b [
Musique]
b sh z
b
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Sher
oh